a challenge in visual storytelling
because that things should be much more
about what things feel like than what
they look like it's also like you know
it's the reason that you run behind on
schedule
we've got crew and in the hallway it's
just a number of really quick on-the-fly
decisions to make it's nearly impossible
but nothing great is easy we've used the
term space over home or house because I
think space gives us a chance to kind of
think about it in a more abstract way if
you have a stomach for adventure the
word crazy is just a wonderful
compliment you need a little craziness
to make anything new the world already
has so many amazing things that exist in
some ways we're trying to reduce the
number of new things creatively it's not
just that this is a good design idea
it's what you're doing with a home that
community that they fill their dad is
really really special the idea for the
motion control was to be able to move
sort of through time space of the homes
that were working with it allows the
space in the home to really come alive
we're always trying to dig into what do
some of these things feel like
you get a sense of the history and the
legacy and the importance
I think the difference between a home
and a house
[Music]
you